[Music]
there are very few people
maybe just the five of them on planet
earth
that have gone through what my next
guest has gone through over the last
decade
very very few people on planet earth
that can tell you the stories he can
tell you
and talk to you about the lessons he's
learned liam payne is a
miraculous inspiring complex
very honest very vulnerable very open
book
today he's going to tell you about
things that he probably shouldn't say
and topics that he probably shouldn't
talk about
but just imagine imagine being
catapulted into
stardom at 14 years old and becoming
what many consider to be
the modern day beatles he toured the
world with one direction
they had their ups their downs their
mental health crises
their scandals their relationships and
everything in between you know if i was
16 years old and you asked me what i
wanted to be if i could
you know dream up my life i'd probably
say professional football player
or being in a boy band and traveling the
world seems like a life that we'd all
give everything to have but what you're
going to hear today is very different
and it might just change your mind it
certainly changed mine
so without further ado i'm stephen
bartlett and this is the driver ceo
i hope nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
[Music]
liam crazy crazy year society
all of us have had with this whole
lockdown situation place wanted to start
it's just to ask how it's been for you
it has been interesting i feel like i
got the lock down the first depressive
part of lockdown
a lot later than everybody else because
our work went through the roof
and basically it was interesting because
i had to learn
styling makeup hair all these things
that i wouldn't usually
do when i'm with my team and i lost
everyone because you couldn't have
anyone close contact so i just had me
and a camera guy that was staying with
me
so every job was like i mean we even had
one day where we set up our own green
screen
and we set the green screen up from 1pm
until
10 and then record it till 5 o'clock in
the morning so it was like a whole day
so we were busier than ever and then we
started doing these online shows which
weren't really great
um with a company called veeps which was
good
and then i stopped working which i
thought was going to be really good for
me because i was tired and it was
actually the worst thing in the world
for me when you say you stopped working
describe your day at that point um i
mean i was just finding myself on the
sofa
for the whole day just watching
randomness i've seen everything on
netflix
on your own uh no my partner's there at
the time okay yeah
it was it was it was wild and it was
dark because you can't really go
anywhere you don't really know what
you're doing and
and and and i felt like my career was
kind of in a funny place at that point
as well and how i was agreeable with it
at that time
as well if that makes sense are you the
type of person that needs to be
kept busy i think so i think i've had a
crash course this last year in learning
to have
my own time because i mean you imagine
from from about the age of
16 17 we were daishi every day so when
you don't have a day sheet it's like
what the hell do i
do and then the other part of it's like
you don't really learn what you enjoy
from that point either so it was that
that was quite difficult in lockdown
because you have so much time to
yourself
and then it was like i saw something the
other day about toxic
productivity did you see this i've seen
this obviously they got a new ism
yeah for everything but it actually made
sense to me if i'm not doing something
that's
that's productive i feel like i'm going
backwards so that i'm trying to make i'm
trying to force moves and i suppose that
was one of the things i think i learned
most about myself i don't have to be
doing something every day to feel
good about myself where does that come
from do you think that need to feel like
you're moving forward
or it feels like backward motion i have
no idea i think i'm just quite driven in
that sense
have you always been like that since
before one direction
you know i think we we just always
worked like i started
i was first on tv at 14. so that's young
it was tweaking an audience specs which
i think that point was like 20 million
people which was wild
so i was like 14 years old so from then
on my life's just been like
doing the same thing over and over and
over again until this point so i don't
know
at times you fall out of love with it
and i think that that trying to find
you know and also you're not under any
impression this isn't going to stop at
some point
like a a life span for a average pop
star i've been i've
outlived most lifespans with that sort
of thing which has been amazing
really really cool and i think part of
that's probably from starting so young
but
you know it's going to end at some point
so you always want to find something
else that you're good at
so it's kind of safety cushioning
this is what investing has been my
god-sending that because i started that
really young as well and trying to think
about how i would do this or how i do
that asking like
you know like our old managers and and
people like that what they invest in and
stuff like that which
kind of makes me feel safer and does
that that comes from a plate like mild
paranoia that this
might go someday right 400 it's like
doomsday profit like probably
you know do you worry a lot generally
uh i think i did
up until the last few months i mean
having a lot of time i think a lot of
people had this same sort of thing
alcohol it was just really it was
getting earlier and earlier
yes easier and easier to go to and for
me i don't know i
it's i think there's there's a slight
little bit of social anxiety as well in
it that
you know it was already hard sometimes
to go out places for the thought that
you might like
packed or whatever you know there's
always that extra level of stress so for
me i've always been quite
withdrawn so talking about lockdown so
you go through that sort of depressive
period
i think we all went through that and i
think um for me what i kept thinking
about is like
if you just um go with the lockdown
you're like someone like me would just
probably like hang around bed on my lap
you know my laptop what i had to do was
like proactively
steve get up and do something today go
put your shoes on [ __ ] you know
what i mean
but then the thing what i found about
that was sometimes
you ain't superman and you're gonna have
a bad day and my thing is if i don't set
out with my
aiming to do that day then i become more
depressive that makes sense
but it's just like i think the main
thing for me i mean i've always called
it like a small victories thing and
that's why i love the gym
because if i've at least been to the gym
that day then i've done something
but then i started to like branch that
out more that it was called a family
member you know i spend some time with
my son make sure i get face timing
because it was the first point of it we
couldn't see each other it was the
longest i haven't seen my son in a long
time
um which was difficult but then it was
like as long as i've done one of those
things in the day then it doesn't matter
if i didn't do anything else
and it's like what i found more than
anything
at least with alcohol with all the stuff
it's like boundaries there were no
boundaries
so you know if you're on zoom you can
quite easily hide that you might be a
little bit tipsy at the point you
shouldn't be
so it was like creating your own
boundaries creating your own routines
and that's where i think everybody
struggled
the most without routine and i noticed
you had a dog here yeah which at the
moment that's one of my things i think
i'm definitely going to get a dog
because i need
routine i need it so you start you start
drinking more and more during the
lockdown you realize you get you're
aware i put on so much weight i was
eating badly
and kind of described describing it as a
bulking period
it was a dirty bulk don't worry about
intentional i'm doing it for a movie
role
yeah that's the best new new excuse if
anyone asks you put weight yes for a
roll
it's coming out you know 20 20 too um
yeah and i put a lot of weight on and
what got me i did one performance on tv
it was with the baftas actually
and i was disappointed myself but like i
was always a fairly sporty kid and kept
moving and like
i didn't look how i wanted to look you
know what i mean there's anything wrong
with that but just in your own self you
know how you feel about it and obviously
they say the camera adds 10 pounds it
definitely did
um and i saw myself for the first time i
was like oh my god like i've completely
let myself go in this
and it was fine i kind of needed it and
actually it's been the best outcome for
me because i feel so much more
secure in myself now and i feel like i
know where i'm at again which is good
have you struggled to maintain
consistency with the gym
i know i have if you look like i did i
did i mean
training partners is the best one for
that you know and and
each of you put putting a session
together and throwing in different moves
because then you're doing something
that's a bit different you know i mean
we recently
my training partner i got to like a
point where we're like a stalemate with
the stuff that we're doing so then we we
started like branching out to different
gyms and they have different kit and
then
you know um but i'm fair i'm fairly good
with keeping myself
on the go with it um i mean
like i said the only problem for me was
just alcohol you can't train and drink
and anything you can't do it all at once
you're gonna be a rock star are you
gonna be a star industry yeah that's
your choice
and do you think you've gotten a bit of
a sort of addicted personality in that
regard where you'll get into something
and just go all the way i mean
as an as an addict i want to say no but
i know i definitely
do um yeah 100 i i think but
there's a lot worse things to be
addicted to than then look after
yourself
so yeah what's been the the upside for
you a lot of people listening to this
well especially coming out of lockdown
now there's a lot of people that weren't
able to go to the gyms because they were
closed
and now that you know some people just
need that little bit of a push
to understand what the value is of the
gym um and what's it what's the value of
the gym been
in your life i think because you're
going twice tonight the value of the gym
yeah yeah i mean i wouldn't call the
first one
the first one's more of like a wake up
let's call it a vinyasa like a yoga type
i the first day i went to the gym in
lockdown i went and looked at the gym
because i was like if i go in there and
start moving around and throwing stuff
and whatever else
then i'm i'm not going to want to go the
next day and you have to slowly build it
up but don't go in and think you need to
do
45 minutes because they're running the
magazine that they said this there's no
quick route for me it's three you need
three months for any significant
change that you have and then it's like
start 20 minutes
15 minutes just go and feel it out and
then you'll find
after a while the exercises you're like
oh my god i only have five more minutes
in here and i need another five minutes
and guess what you can have them
so then it's slowly like we've got we're
up to you know an hour an hour and 10
minutes now so it's like from
starting at 15 20 minutes but for me
it's just
like i say it's been able to get into
bed at night and have that small victory
to know
at least i did this and it was for me it
wasn't for anybody else
that's i think that's important and
you're not doing it to try and
get a sick i mean everyone's doing it
low key to try and get six-pack but
you're doing it because
it's a lifestyle decision for your yeah
i mean i recently started
jiu jitsu and it's for me i want to be
able to do
what a lot of these guys are doing like
the funny thing jiu-jitsu is super
humbling because you just get thrown
around like
it's like a tiger eating a gazelle or
something i mean
it's wild so it's like as soon as it
happens and i was always quite a small
dude i've never been like a big guy um
i mean even when i did my underwear
commercial i was still like
80 i think i was 75 kilos which is super
light right super life so
when i'm in the gym people are like
throwing me over here and i'm like i'm
going that way today am i then i'm over
here and it's like
so i put i didn't want to put some
weight and i put too much weight on at
one point i was like
right i went alpha leather but it's more
for the the
fitness side and the jujitsu side that
i'm training as hard as i am
if you want to come in and meet guests
like liam and myself we've now had two
subscribers come in and watch from
behind the scenes
we're going to start picking more so all
you've got to do if you want that to be
you
is hit the subscribe button i wanted to
ask you some advice
i've been announced as a dragon on
dragon's den and how do you feel about
that by the way
it's pretty cool it's cool because
you're a dragon like when some kids want
to grow up being a dragon yeah
yeah i know i i watched it when i was
12. so it came out when i was 12. i used
to watch it and i've never missed an
episode wow that doesn't matter
i said to the team i used to pretend i
was a dragon sit there
pause the tv give my verdict at 13 years
old
all this stuff um the bit i wanted to
ask your advice on
is when it was announced you know i had
my little moment 15 seconds where like
all of the press talk about you your
twitter blows up
lots of attention what advice would you
give to me
about dealing with this kind of noise
because you i mean
there's not many people on planet earth
that have dealt with
noise like that right
i think don't it's a really fine line
between getting too wrapped up in what's
going on and
not being wrapped up enough in it if you
know what i mean really i think i think
you know the things that hurt you the
most because you know they're honest
so when someone says something new like
if they hurt you then you hurt you a lot
then you know there's some truth in it
because it hurt you if it's ridiculous
you just go that was funny
as if they said that you know what i
mean really so i think there's a there's
a fine line to tread with it and i mean
i've gone through eras where i was just
like a little clap back
attitude driven you responding where as
soon as someone would say something i'd
be like right well then
let's go with you and then i was i mean
i was a bit mean and nasty at points
actually it was a bit bad but
when you're a teen growing up in it and
people are like basically bullying you
and they get paid for it it's like
that's a bit outrageous so i'm gonna
have my say
who's got the biggest mountain you know
what i mean but then it's like someone
said to me over time it's like
you know if someone says something about
me in the press in this country and then
i say something about them
it ends up on e news and then they've
made america i didn't get anywhere
so it's like don't bring people up to
your level if you don't think you unless
you absolutely have to and one thing i
would say
don't lose your phone doing this notes
if someone
pisses you off write a note about it as
if you were writing them a letter and
then let it go
just don't send it and then it gets all
your
well you would tweet out but you don't
say it
that was the best thing i ever did it
was the best thing i ever did
really yeah so pop open your notes then
i just remembered one imagine [ __ ]
out no it's crazy because you read stuff
and i was saying to you
before we start filming like i've got a
baby apparently and a wife and then
you know yourself i know you're doing
really well yeah and i just thought
you know it's crazy that um there's not
a high regard for truth
you know what i was actually on the way
into this i wanted to speak about this
because
obviously there's a lot in the in the
world at the moment about freedom of
speech and the press freedom of speech
which i agree with right we should we
don't need to dictate laws
my only problem is and my biggest
problem around corona
was the fact that the media were allowed
to twist our
thinking about corona as much as they
wanted to and they're still doing it now
but the fear mongering isn't helping
anyone
you know and these people aren't sat
there i know i've just written a great
article my boss is going to promote me
oh yeah but you just decrease the value
of the pound
so your wages that you think are worth
more are now worth less
well it's a struggling industry right i
just don't get it i'm like
if it's a medical thing and it's the
world that is in trouble
maybe there should have to be something
in place that says this is true
or not that they have to put a
disclaimer and say you should take
advice from your local government
[ __ ] like we all read you for advice
and you are offering us a disservice by
telling us non-truths about stuff it
should be regulated
yeah i get that there's a hairdresser's
account for me for people going oh my
god i can't believe what that liam
payne's done this week
what's he done now you know i get that
but for corona
yeah yeah we don't need to be going oh
yeah have you read the thing about this
new variant that's come from over the
border yeah i can't believe it
like someone from america phoned me the
other night like oh you're gonna be able
to come here soon i'm like
no i ain't no chance but we don't none
of us know we're all confused because
we're being
spouted fear which i just think is
terrible social media doesn't help
either because
there's screenshots knocking around
whatsapp group saying all sorts of
yeah i mean that as much as this
technology advancing on us
it's like this slow road i mean it's
almost like the coins
thing at the moment with the the
bitcoins like there's some coins they're
actually seriously there to do a job in
the ship and then there's like the
[ __ ] elon musk coin yeah there's nothing
but just disrespect to love
like five billion like a bunch of like
it's
actually nuts um you said earlier you
made a comment you said that um
your partner at the time in referring to
lockdown does that mean you are
i am indeed you're single yep me and you
both
where are we going no i'm saying to
myself
i feel like i feel like more than
anything at this point i'm more
disappointed in myself
for the keep on hurting people
that annoys me i've just been not been
very good at relationships and i know
what my pattern of things
is with relationships i feel at this
point i'm just not very good at them so
i just need to like work on myself
before i put myself onto somebody else
and i feel that's what you know that's
why i got to my last relationship i just
wasn't given
a very good version of me anymore that i
didn't appreciate and i didn't like
being
and i can honestly say that i feel
better out of it i didn't feel good for
doing what
what i did but it had to happen i mean
that's the
corniest way of saying that was the best
for both of us whatever cool story bro
but it just feels like that very
self-aware for you to know that
you were oh yeah no i know it was a
problem so
i need to sort myself out and i already
feel good so
it's got me more concentrated you know
and i hope she's happy
what is it you've discovered about
yourself in relationships that you're
trying to work on
you know what i mean
one of our old managers went to therapy
from being a manager of one direction so
we can imagine how that feels like the
rest of us definitely need some
and for me most part i was really
regressing from
therapy because everyone was pushing me
into it which is the worst thing you can
do
like it's almost like becoming sober for
instance you have to want to be sober
to start with not people taking your
toys away and you're going oh my god so
it kind of felt like that whereas this
time i kind of threw myself into it
even though i didn't want didn't really
want to inside i threw myself into it
made my own choices and
i think for me my life's been so
controlled to a point
day sheets security guards you know
anything and it's all
everybody else is dictating puppet
master crap over the top of your life
then you just get to point where it's
like you have to take some control by
yourself and until i
started to do that with my life then i
was living for everybody else
and i'm a complete people pleaser anyway
so it was like nothing in my life was
about
serving myself which then that just put
me in a bad place and finding enjoyment
from other stuff that i don't need
what did because i've always considered
therapy
for a bunch of reasons and the thing is
it's still such like a
taboo kind of crazy thing and i get it i
do get it i was i mean i was on the
phone to louis from my band talking
about it today and it's like
there was one moment last week and i
mean my manager's my best friend he's
been saying to me for a long time you'll
have that one awakening in the middle of
it where you'll think about stuff
tonight
i mean i hate words like awakening and i
hate this like hollywood perception of
like
reflective work what the [ __ ] is that
you know what i mean but i get it but at
the same point i'm like
i don't know you keep it for you but
it's like i had this one moment that
that i found and i was like oh my god
that's just unlocked so many truths
about me and it was so insignificant
for something that happened when i was
younger and it was so to me it was like
a family joke
but now i'm like oh my god i've been
living my whole life as that character
and
yeah wild wild you'll love it scary
really scary you don't know what you're
gonna find it's like no that's it it's
wild but
i'm i'm so glad that i one went through
what i went through this year
and two that you know i think this
year's forced something out of all of us
and for me it forced me to really look
at my life and go
what the f are you doing like grow up
and that was the point
and you say don't try to work on that
but did you regressed from therapy
yeah i always turned away from it and i
was always like oh i don't i don't need
therapy i'll sort myself out
you know your own worst enemy at that
point i'm really keen to understand
what makes you a difficult you know
specifically what makes you a difficult
person today i ask this question
because i'm difficult to put a few
people in it
coming on down his best friend oh my god
every ex-girlfriend we've got a behind
the curtain
now that would be a weird room imagine
that drops down in there
oh my god
what would be the the consistent theme
as to why you're difficult today if
i think i i think my problem i struggle
to be on my own sometimes
really yeah struggle be on my own and i
think i'd dive in and out of
relationships too quickly
and i've not had to spend enough time on
my own to really learn
about myself if that makes sense i
honestly just need a minute
i need to check myself but i'm really
i'm really keen so you
needed to spend some time on your own to
kind of understand yourself because in a
relationship context you find
that you kind of you're in and you're
out a little bit too much is that what
you're saying
yeah and i i i don't know i think the
biggest problem we have
i'm proper perfectionist terrible
terrible terrible
so when it comes down to relationships
i'm always trying to star the
relationship as we all do you put out
this complete false character yes like i
might as well go in costume
that's why i'm like putting out
something that he's not there
is the person is absent from the room
it's like they tag teamed on the way in
on oh it's you for this bit yeah
i'll join in later on and uh i just yeah
i just need to stop doing that and then
kind of like one
encompassing someone else's life with
your crap rather than like
just doing your thing and laying out
your store from day one that's my
biggest problem and i feel for my for
myself i don't lay out my store
i'm like willing to bend to someone
else's store and then i'm annoyed at why
they don't like what i like
amen so then i'm like oh okay but if i
just laid out the stall early on and
like
yeah i go up at 5am and go for a run
well how are we going to deal with that
so he's either in or it's not you know
what i mean it's not not to not
compromise
because some things you'll be like okay
that annoys you fine but
yeah for me i don't i don't do that i
lay out a completely different
it's like a war worth when you wanted an
artist or you know
that's i've really debated that i'm
gonna
personally especially recently because
the girl i was into
is very into everything that i'm not
into
like like she's into like horoscopes and
like i don't know what's wrong with us
whatever i don't know so i'm there like
[ __ ] looking at horoscopes being like
no yeah
because you're trying to make spiritual
people scare me
but at the start of a relationship you
become more like them they become more
like you and then there's a couple of
weeks months pass
you just regress to actually who you
actually are well you almost like i feel
like i hide resentments
from people sometimes and i'm like
something annoys me and i'm like oh
no it's fine but instead i'm thinking
jesus christ i wish she didn't do that
and then so then it's like then over
time i'm like every little thing starts
creeping in and i did this in my job
really badly because i would bend to my
job
and let my job overtake things that i
didn't like doing steve will vaccinate
like videos for stuff
and rather than going no until one day i
just was like i hate everything
and now it's almost gone back the other
way now i've had to still reset that
like i'm starting to call people in to
do what i want to do rather than bending
to everybody else's stuff
you know and this cr you'll probably
experience the same in this you're
pulled every which way
you know and it's always about
impressing whoever's behind the lens
whoever's in the audience so i find i
feel conversations with crap that i'm
saying that
doesn't really help me because i'll go
home thinking why the hell did i say
that
what now i'm that guy oh my god you know
and then and then it's like but i was
saying it because i thought it would
entertain the other person
it wasn't about me stupid
it's really fascinating that you're so
self-aware of all these forces at play
because it feels like you've spent a
long time really analyzing and looking
at your behavior i think that
that can that can have its benefits and
it can have its problems as well i think
i'm like over critical at points but you
know
you can't win everything being a
perfectionist
yep it's an issue yeah what how
to talk to me about what that means
specifically in your life in work
in relationships steve in everything
steve's manager who sat behind the
camera
um i feel like we should publish
i know what i love about this is that
but steve my fans think that like
steve's like doing something to me so
they're always like oh liberty fellaini
he always looks for steve but it's only
because i like him
because not because he's like harming me
as a person but then there's like a
hashtag liberty for liam like they think
i'm like
sort of like prison child there's going
to be all these other people who are
just listening on the audio and think
you're calling my name
steve
so my one thing i really got into over
over lockdown was art
and drawing oh interesting something
i've done since i was younger and
the point was find something to do that
doesn't make you money
was the whole point of the exercise i
was like okay cool draw it
i said to the person who gave me the
advice at the time i was like i
guarantee this turns into something
hold for later on in the conversation um
so i started drawing but then what i
found was
i was so bad at starting the task blank
sheet of paper and all that
because i was so worried about what
might come out that i was like i'd sit
there like if something's not quite
right i like
it can ruin my day in a drawing if
something goes wrong and it's not quite
right i'm like oh my god
like i hate it that's the kind of thing
and how did that go okay i mean the
thing is once i got started and got onto
some stuff but then it was like
sometimes in that respect then i was
drinking to draw pictures because i was
so
in my own freaking way and it's the same
writing songs as well you can do the
same thing with everything you can trade
out all that crap
and it's like that's why you know people
might smoke a bit or do whatever when
they
when they make a track but it's all
about getting out your own way and i
feel like
now i feel much more like i know who i
am and i know what i want to do so i
don't need to be in my own way i'm going
to go
you know i don't need these additives
they only make me worse anyway
in the long run right oh my god yeah
tonight today it might help but tomorrow
it's going to it's probably
true and are you still drinking reviews
no not some no no i've been sober just
over a month now i think it is
hey my business partner he um when we
started the business
became an alcoholic about three four
years in because it was just too tough
and then he had like
severe suicidal ideation he actually
didn't tell me at the time and this is
why i was reading about your story
i could relate to so much of it because
he i didn't
say what i was going through to him he
didn't say it to me and then it was like
after we'd solved the business that he
was like i used to stand on the train
platforms and think about jumping in
front of the train
and i was like and he never told me and
but there was and you
i didn't know what alcoholism or really
mental health was at the time
but i'd go downstairs 3am in the morning
and i'd open up the laundry room
and he's in there with a bottle of wine
at 3am the lights are off and he's just
drinking it
sat on the clothes i'm like get off my
[ __ ] clothes
i was like what the hell is going on but
you know and i read similar things
similar sort of
story or narratives in your story where
you know you were having moments of that
that kind of like ideation
you were having moments of suicidal
ideation and yeah i mean
there's there's some stuff that i've
definitely like never never spoken about
to do with it it was really really
really severe
and it was a problem and and and it was
only until i saw myself after that i was
alright i need to fix myself
there's a few pictures of me on a boat
and i'm all like blowing out and i call
it pills and boo's face
and i was like this like my face was
just like 10 times more than it is now
and i just didn't like myself very much
then i made a change and the same thing
happened this year with with that sort
of thing as well but
the problem we had in the band and i
don't blame anybody for this i don't
want to seem like i'm whining or moaning
oh my god look at my life whatever
but it feels to me like when we were in
the band the best way to secure us
because of how big it got
was just lock us in our rooms and of
course what's in the room minibar
so at a certain point i thought well i'm
going to have a party for one and that
just seemed to carry on throughout
many years of my life and then you look
back how long you've been drinking and
stuff you're like jesus christ that's a
long time
even for someone who's you know as young
as i was um
it was wild but it was like the only way
you could get frustration out in the day
or
being like trapped and you know i spoke
about to somebody about this and
in child development you know as a teen
the one thing you need is
is freedom to make choices and freedom
to do stuff and it was the one thing
that
although we could do anything we wanted
it seemed from the outside that we were
always
locked in a room at night and then it
would be car hotel room stage
sing blocked so it was like they pulled
the dust cloth off let us out for a
minute and then
and then he's like back underneath here
and i'm like so crazy because
you're right the public will think the
absolute opposite we think uh
one direction those guys have got total
freedom
all the money and what they can do
anything everyone's you know in their
nine-to-five jobs just thinking i'd love
to have that level of freedom that liam
payne has
to do anything but you can't do anything
right it's the opposite no i mean
because we were young i mean i actually
wanted to speak to you about this then
as well
so obviously you've reached
stratospheric heights young age it's
like
what i found was i didn't know i was the
boss until a long
until like a few months ago i still
don't even feel like i am now like i'm
such a child
and everyone i work with is like don't
be right older than me and wiser than me
and i'm like what the hell am i doing
here with these people
so it's like you you you know when we
were 17 i thought the security guard was
like in charge of me like i was like oh
can we leave the room no
okay then not to worry i'll just stay
here that's what it was like so i didn't
know what the hell i was doing
you know what i mean it's like and no
one there's no guidebook they don't give
you a little
dvd on the way and saying here you're a
pop star this is what you got to do
so i'm like in the room like what are we
allowed to leave and then eventually
that becomes
like an angry person and i was because
there was points where it was toxic and
it was difficult
don't get me wrong we had the best time
ever we did
but there was moments where
through you know i mean there's a
there's a big movement on it at the
moment and people overworking and
like you don't realize you have a choice
at that point
but in those shows sometimes they don't
give you the choice because you want the
dream but you have to realize
there is a sacrifice for that you know
rather than it just and like i say i
never want to come on on these things
and whine about stuff like i made my own
choices in life
you know being an alcoholic doing
whatever else that weren't my choice
so you know it it doesn't have to be
whiny but it's just like
there was a sacrifice and i know what i
did sacrifice to be here
you know everything what i've come to
learn
everything in life all the good [ __ ]
comes with a cost
oh and i've i've learned just from my
own experience like
my success my sex is very different from
yours we went very different paths
but came with a clear cost because you
can't go from being uh
18 year old kid that's like nick in
chicago town pizzas to feed himself
to being to building a company by 300
million within six seven years
what a great sentence that was by the
way like i was a [ __ ]
loser like loner like i was in my room
first summers upon summers
on my own for just you know because i
couldn't my parents weren't talking to
me they said don't call us and to go
back to university years on my so he
wasn't speaking to my family
no friends because i couldn't even
afford to see him that was the cost for
me and what that made is someone who
again isn't very social on the weekends
i spend
99 of my time alone and people are like
oh my god i'd love to be i'm like well
and then and then i have the same thing
you have which is my brain is always has
a thousand tabs open and i can't just go
and sit on a sun lounge during
tan like tan tiny nights what's my brain
gonna do then
sitting in the bathtub as well but
that's it you're right and you know what
like think about someone as simple as
someone who like plays guitar
the amount of time you have to spend
alone with that instrument you're gonna
be missing a couple of other things that
happen in life exactly
and that's what it's like exactly and
that's for us for us as teams growing up
you know i think people like i said i
started at 14.
that's nuts like i was in my school i
remember very clearly the moment that
that that x factor like moment happened
when i was when i was younger
and i was playing football on a field
and we had an all-girls school right
next door to us
so i'm just playing football like it's a
normal day i've had a few like people
like shout me out on the street where i
was like oh i'm you know
14 years old the whole school from the
other school
is on the fence i'm like banned from
that field for life
at first how does it feel it was wild
but what their people
dialed yeah it was it was amazing i was
like i went from like
zero to like i was the you know it was i
think
i always say it's people i wasn't world
famous when i was 14 but i was famous
within my world
so it's like well i didn't leave
wolverhampton and everybody in
wolverhampton knew the hell i was so i
couldn't go anywhere
so you know and at that point i can't
afford a security guard i'm not special
enough to have any of these like
additives
i'm still on the 7948 to
you know my little my little christian
school and then
what happened over time is and
you know people are people they they do
what they do but there was there was one
significant moment for me
where i knew that i lost it and i wasn't
gonna go back on x factor to be in the
band which would have been wild by the
way
i would not have been here right now um
but there was a moment i was in a
mcdonald's with like a new girlfriend i
had at the time
and it had been two years since the show
and i noticed my
shows decreased in number decreased in
capacity
and decreased in wages so i was like
down and out at this point so i've had
fame and lost it and i'm like
nearly 16 years old so that's difficult
to deal with anyway at that age and then
i'm in mcdonald's
because everyone still knows who i am
i'm sat there and i literally remember
about take a bite this nice juicy burger
someone on the stairs goes
x factor reject and the whole restaurant
looks at me right i'm
15 years old and it was just horrible
what a scumbag thing to say
i know but it was like that's that's the
thing it's like it was almost
like a shout out to say oh you think
you're special but you're still here
in the most wolverhampton i guess you've
got to understand where that comes from
though from that person
what's going on well someone said
something to me today it's not what you
do it's what's happened to you
which i thought was quite i like that
quick interjection
as you know you'll sponsor this podcast
and i've been the biggest evangelist and
customer of the brand for for many many
years i drink cure
for a set of very clear reasons if i
don't drink heal
i skip meals because i'm very very busy
and the meals that i end up skipping it
for um don't tend to be the most sort of
nutritionally complete fuel is
nutritionally complete
it means that in sometimes in 20 seconds
i can get
a meal in a bottle that tastes great
that's going to take care of my health
and for me
as you would have known if you've
listened to this podcast for some time
my health is my first foundation
today you'll have released a new product
it's the huel protein
powder 20 grams of protein in a hundred
calories roughly tasty as [ __ ] and it's
vegan
highly highly recommend trying it i've
tried it i love it
and i'm going to evangelize it for about
it from now on
so tell me what happens from there so
you i don't want to go too much into it
because i know you get asked this stuff
all the time
so we don't want to go over old tracks
but that was your first sort of
experience with fame you then kind of
you feel it declining ice cube says some
stuff to you in the mcdonald's
live life carries on and then uh yeah on
the point because i really want to get
to this i know you're working on this
nft project
yeah and it's based around this feeling
of being it's based around the idea of
this
it was it was like a i want to call it a
syndrome i don't know what it was
someone told me something about
fame you enter fame the age
you you leave fame the age you entered
it so for me that was 14 right so i'm
screwed
like i'm the 14 year old forever child
so that was always a big fear of mine
that i have to grow
properly now from what one direction
gave me i grew
massively in some respects to the point
that yeah i mean you all have
experiences when you have conversations
about
business deals and i'm the director of
like i was a director of a half a
billion dollar
industry at 22. and i'm like what the
hell does that mean all it meant was i
got to sign 10 times more forms than
anybody else
wild right so but then in other things
like if i'm trying to pay car insurance
i'm useless
so that you don't grow in other aspects
of your life because you have other
people
do crap for you like picking up my post
i'm the worst person in the world i just
forget about it you know that must lead
you
open to be to be taken advantage of
right because they know that there's
some things you don't know like you're
saying
oh yeah yeah that's it and you're you're
deluded in your growth of whatever but
this is where the nft idea kind of came
from and it but it first started as this
this little drawing that i did and now i
wanted to make my own character because
i was like i'm really good at drawing
but we have printers for that i don't
need to be a printer so then i was like
i need to make something so i made this
like
ethereal creature that was i wanted to
3d print and stick in a uh like crystal
glass
box and the idea is that he's depressed
that he's it's like a wasp in a beer
glass type thing
ah okay magical creature can't get out
sort of thing so then we kind of came up
with this peritoneus idea
around fame and what does that lead to
and for me the way it speaks to me and
the way the art speaks to me
is that i was afraid of the idea of
losing
you know having keeping the child with
me i was trying to it was like a monkey
on my back trying to get rid of him
whereas for now the idea for me is more
based around you know how do i enjoy
that
because what i love when i see my son
is that he can be whatever he wants in
that moment you know i'll be over the
house and he's like you're a bad guy i'm
a good guy
and i'm like that's great and then the
next day he's
one of them girls from frozen no no i'm
doing this it's magic powers today and
i'm like wow
like we lose that and that's a lot of my
problem when i'm sitting doing a task or
whatever
the belief system in me has been trodden
on through life that much that now i've
forgotten about that
they have the ability to do whatever the
hell they want so why would you ever
want to
lose the child within you in that sense
wow
and that's coming out as an nft soon
coming out as an nfc
uh in like two weeks i think it's quite
scary it's wild because i just made it i
made it one day in lockdown and then
sent it to my manager and we enjoyed the
pieces it was but then it just kind of
grew into this thing at the same time
that nfts were growing
right that's the thing i mean have you
how many people ask you what nfts are by
the way
um so many of them a lot of people like
i'll get dms all the time and you know
i'll try and describe what it is but
i think if you say something with enough
conviction people just believe it anyway
so i'm like you know broccoli yeah i'm
like no i'm just saying anything
yeah i know what it is i've studied it
i'm working on a few projects at the
moment with nfts but um
i'm just you know with all these
emerging technologies and whenever
something's new
i'm kind of like probably a little bit
like you and christian i know you're
very very entrepreneurial and
investing a lot now um i just want to
be in there like a sponge so i want like
a
a flag in there just so i can learn so
yeah
well i mean i think that's a common
misconception about this sort of thing
as well
is that you always come up with the idea
that's coming to you rather than like
you say being that sponge in the middle
of the room
if you're not part of the million dollar
conversation you were never part of the
[ __ ] conversation
and that's literally it's like be in the
moment like rather than trying to make
decisions or
you just have to learn about that stuff
and you don't have to know everything
you just have to know someone that does
know something you know what i mean yeah
the thing is you get older i think the
wildest thing is that people
those phrases that they used to say to
you as kids like when i had my child
my mom's saying to me oh like you're
growing up so quickly like blinking
you'll miss it
and like you're a kid you're like yeah
i'm sick so i chill out but then as you
get older you're like watching it and i
watch my song i'm like oh my god
yeah he's telling me off now
they grew up so fast my niece i mean
i've got a child of mine according to
the daily mail but you know just like
this where did you get those legs from
um i've been teaching mine to swim i
mean we had a really good conversation
today and it's like it's a whole new
learning experience once again there's
no handbook
and you're just like out there on your
own i still feel like a child in so many
ways
as you've learned from my nfc yeah yeah
but i'm watching him and like i played
him a trailer a movie trailer it was
this simple i played him trailer for a
thing and we watched it
and we both like i like that let's stick
that on it was just disney's
rayo and the dragon thing it was about
you
you and your newfound friend and uh
so we sat there and then i turned the
film on and the first shot of the film
was from the trailer
he's going why are you playing this
again i'm going no no it was
we watched a trailer no but why is it on
the tv again
and it kept like bits get flashing and
i'm like oh my god this is not helping
me
so then i'm like okay let me how do i
explain this i was like you know like if
we like have a plate food
and like i feed you a little bit and
then you go oh and you don't want it
then i take it away or if i feed someone
you go oh yeah and i give you the whole
thing
i was like that's like this and then
he's going
yeah but why are we watching it again
you must do you get scared as a dad
about doing the wrong thing or the right
thing because you say there's no
handbook so you're like
if you feed him this or if you say this
he's going to start saying the c word
at school like i do oh when he did swear
once i was happy i wasn't around for it
because i couldn't be blamed
and there's a way to root out find out
whose swear word it is
because it wasn't a combination i would
use oh really so i knew it wasn't me
mummy who was it who was it we won't go
into that
you said i don't normally loop back but
there was something you said which
which again my mind thought oh that's
really intriguing is you said that you
weren't going to reapply for the x
factor
potentially where do you think you would
be
and i'm going to ask you various
iterations of these questions where do
you think you'd be in your life now
if you hadn't have applied for the x
factor so you won the business plan
that's what yeah yeah that's what you
really want to hear do you want to hear
this
yeah you know hey i'll lay out for you
this is this is my this is actually my
like plan b systems range child okay
so i got a job at the same time this is
really wild
work experience week at school my dad
worked at a factory and i was always
obsessed i was like this is adult lego
and he built aeroplanes i was like this
is amazing i'm gonna do that
so i went and i built airplanes and they
had like a little collection for me
different i did like 400 quid and
everyone i was like what did you get
paid for your work experience so i was
like
nothing i was like oh i got like 500
quid but in the middle of my work
experience i went on x factor so it was
almost like i was trialing
my two lives almost like uh what's that
sliding doors film or whatever it's
called a butterfly effect or oh yeah
yeah so my thing was i got a job and
secured one
there for an apprenticeship which was
like 22 000 a year or something
and then i was like right i know my
sister paid 60 pound board at the house
so if i just like board at my parents
house it's 60 pound in fees
then i can save up the other money
enough to buy my first house and then
rent it out
all right so i was gonna collect the
rent buy another one and then move into
that one and then it was almost like a
conveyor belt system nice you had it all
planned out i had it ready to go
and then x factor room i mean you say
your your favorite tv program was
dragons then mine
was i watched help my house is falling
down and location location location and
stuff like that when i was a kid i was
like
obsessed yeah and then for enough my
manager does
loads of properties are you in the odds
are you into property i love property
really i i wasn't very good at it at the
start but i'm getting better
you need to teach me some stuff because
i have zero properties i'm renting this
place um
i was going to say to you um with them
when you do a show like x factor
what a lot of the sort of people that
come out the other end of these shows
often say especially i mean very few
have had the success that you've had
right
but i can imagine and i think i've i
think i might have read this somewhere
before maybe from little mix
is you you feel somewhere in you that
you still have something to prove
because
talk to me about that i mean because
your success was
is just stratospheric it's like in a
league of its own
it's wild so to hear that you feel like
you still have something to prove
is surprising well i mean i think
there's a problem that
us as people we all want something that
we feel like we made
but the older i get and the more things
i'm like privy to
you don't really make anything on your
own ever like i think it's just about ed
sheeran the rights on his own even he
doesn't write music on his own so it's
like
for one that feels a little bit like
that because you were in the band and i
suppose
for each of us as members we wanted to
see what we could do and i you know i'm
really happy with my success
as well what i don't know is
how how much of this idea was was mine
to go with as to be in the music career
you know you worry about like the life
that you might have missed over i was
gonna do this whatever
i always quite like the idea of the army
as a kid that's something i definitely
wanted to do sas
yeah i love the idea of the army and
boxing's another one i mean i've been
i've been fortunate to have a bunch
of fun stuff um but yeah i think you
always feel like you have something to
prove and i think the end of the day
you're just you're only really proving
it to yourself because no one else
really cares everyone else just looks at
you as what it is
and it's not that you want to beat your
brand because no one will beat
our one direction not one of us in our
lifetimes in another lifetime somebody
might
might crack something i mean bts have
had a really good go at it they've done
really really well
um but we were like the new wave of the
beatles
and even still people just didn't say we
beat the beatles you know what i mean
you're never gonna
yeah it's different different era
exactly and that's that's what happened
with our fame as well we were just that
of this era
same with justin bieber right who the
hell has beaten that run come on they
won't they'll
someone will be different exactly
exactly so it's just like i think in the
end it's you're only like
fighting against yourself i sound like
rocky barbara now
i'm really intrigued by all of that
because you you also have these five so
you have five band members
they all go off and do their own solo
careers
and i always are you do you compete
against each other do you try and stay
out of each other's lanes are you
thinking about oh my god i don't want to
be
seen as doing you know what this
person's doing i think we did compete
with each other at a point
but i think it's all fairly like it's
laid out as it is now and we've all had
our success in completely different
areas
and also musically we didn't really go
down the same route
i think harry harry's done amazing you
know i mean first album he had the one
song off which is really really well and
then his second album
he found himself and that's that is your
awakening his eyes that's when it really
clicks i don't feel like i've had that
moment within me
yet i've written some songs recently i'm
really proud of and happy with but i
don't feel like i've had that moment yet
stripped that down
came out and it was we did a billion
streams and i could have
never asked the town i could have never
asked for that in a million years but
when i was making strip that down i was
a box of frogs
i was nuts it was wild i didn't know
what the hell was going on and also i
didn't know what the
what the you know the hot potato i just
landed on me are we just a billion
streams it's like
it literally is like hot potato one
minute's here the next minute it's gone
so you know i'm excited to see what the
next
the next six months of this brings you
know
um i'm excited to see to see we have
some
a really cool song in the pipeline um
which
is really exciting wow really exciting
then the song one of the first ones i've
actually
written myself um
with some other people i didn't write by
myself um but it's yeah the first one
i've really liked
and i think i got so used to carting
around other people's songs and not
embedding myself creatively in what i do
because i was
scared to find out who i was
so it's almost like that's the thing
when you're selling yourself you have to
know what the hell you're selling and
i'm you know i'm sure
most people wake up every day going i
don't know what the [ __ ] is going on and
you have to fail to find that out right
yeah
because you're gonna have to try some
[ __ ] experiment oh my god and it's like
so say like you're like geeky kind of
growing phase between
say 16 to 21 if you're lucky it might
last a bit longer if you're [ __ ]
you i did that in front of everyone and
there's some terrible outfits
there's some terrible haircuts you know
and that's some great
that stuff is there forever i've gotten
away with a few heck yeah
i feel like you've had some great ones
the short haircut i think not a lot of
people can pull that out i gotta have
like a melon head thing at the back so i
can't
i can't do that people think i'm an
alien but um no you've had some good
haircuts i've gotta be honest
when i read something about um strip
that down
you said that you were almost scared of
the success just as much as scared of
the failure oh
man i mean no one trains you for the
moment it goes right right
so you leave one direction you've got
your big sort of debut single coming up
and you're scared of the success i was
really
worried because i know what that can
bring to you
what can i bring well i've never i
i finished a day one of the one days
that stuck out for me the last
few years where i did a whole day's
promo in new york
and on the night time i was on i think
it's an andy cohen show or something
and they had a drinking game and someone
asked me a question about one of my
ex-girlfriends and i did not want to
divulge
what the hell went down and it was a
drinking game so i i was like they were
like we can fill it with water but me
being me was like no if i'm playing i'm
playing for real
so i'm like necking tequila oh gosh boom
and
i'm wasted i get home at half past one
bear in mind i started at like
i want to say eight o'clock in the
morning i was then asleep and i woke up
at half past three
for vocal training to be in central park
at seven for grooming at five and in
central park for seven o'clock
bear in mind i've been to bed at half
past one so i know what it can bring in
that
that crap will send you insane i don't
remember some days i was here
like that will send you round the bend
but it's the you if you want it
if you want it it's out there for you
you can go ahead and take it but it's
like you have to be
a workhorse to want to to do this and i
think a lot of artists would say that
coming out of it but i don't think it's
you know it's unfortunate the demand in
our industry and also the demand of how
quickly people receive information now
you know our 30-second time like
goldfish time span that we've got now
i mean i definitely have that i'm the
worst
and it went really really [ __ ] well
it went really well and then it was like
you know the problem we had was it was
like having a baby the thing
was nine months to get the number one in
america so it took nine months to work
the record just to get the number one
so if you can imagine singing the same
song every day
for nine months and having like one or
two songs to back it up with
it was like pretty like
i'm sure somewhere that must be like put
down as a method of torture yeah
i can imagine you must but this is the
job man and it's like it's
listen the first few shows of anything
are amazing and then after a while it's
like
you'll find bits that will like great on
you and whatever else but you know
i've been so lucky to have the career
that i've had and and
you know let's hope for more of that
that's that's what i think at this point
but it's learning how to deal and
channel that
and what's your relationship like with
the rest of the boys i'm sure you get
asked this all the time
great with most of them um i think
everyone's
settling into themselves at this point i
know i am for sure um
uh i had a lovely phone call from harry
the other day was checking in on me and
and it's almost like some people got
sixth sense for you right that you're
going through something so they'll check
in and he's
very much like that he's a lovely lovely
boy i i love him to pieces and then um
louis i speak to
a lot um and we've always had a really
really close
connection and the funny thing for us
and i've said this a lot but
we we hated each other at the start but
it's almost the people that you grow
closest to you know i mean i'll say it
because he bought it
quite recently but you know the whole
thing gonna talk about the reunion like
for me
i'd rather be talked about it sooner
rather than later because i don't want
to
it's tough touring touring that that
sort of record and then and i enjoyed
touring for what i enjoyed it for but
there's parts of it that really really
[ __ ] me up man in a sense i'll be
honest with you
um but none of us talk about it it's
like his taboo subject like oh we can't
get back together what do you mean oh my
god like us in the same room
what the [ __ ] is that about what [ __ ]
you up about touring uh
my dad said it from day one lonely hotel
rooms man getting locked in that room is
not fun when you've been
exposed i mean i've come off gigs before
i did a gig in
in dubai i was really worried no one was
gonna show up it was one of my first
solo gigs by myself
and i suppose i'm uber self-critical i'm
always like i don't know what the hell
is going on
so i get to this park and the capacity
for the park is like
you've never seen i'm looking at like a
park i'm like the hell
and i'm thinking we're getting paid a
lot of money to be here this is gonna be
really embarrassing if nobody shows up
and i don't know anybody in dubai i
can't even call 10 friends to be here
so i'm like at dinner i'm not eating my
food and whatever else then i get back
to the gig and
there's people chanting and kind of liam
and i'm like okay there's people here oh
my god i can chill
i get out there and i'm like awash with
these sea of people
and i noticed the sound systems hella
quiet behind me this make any sense i'd
get through the gig and you autopilot
the hell out of it
when i got off stage they're like oh you
broke a record you're on a list with
michael jackson
there's 110 000 people i'm like
and i was like i i sh you know i got
back to my hotel room and i was sat in
my room on a chair like this
and i was about to go to the maldives
with uh with cheryl and bear and i'm
like
i don't think i can go to the maldives
right now i can't move off this chair
how did you feel on that chair shocked
why like for to go from like i don't
know who's going to be here
to then i looked on the thing and it's
like oasis robbie williams
all these amazing you know ac dc all
these outdoor gigs amazing outdoor gigs
and then just me and michael jackson and
he's in there like three or four times
he's
you know he is the list but i was on the
same list i'm like what the
it can't be easy like go with a white
hotel room
it's almost like you know like in that
in a movie where they throw a grenade
and he goes
and then everyone's like and you still
feel like you're like oh my god like
yeah because i've done 9 000 50 15 000
in sao paulo i mean i did a talk with
obama that's me name-dropping oh wow
but um but it it they're not chanting
they're all very quiet i mean they clap
at the end but but how did it make you
feel you just feel like a diff
i can completely relate because i i was
thinking last year i lived in new york
city but i was i was speaking around the
world 50 weeks of the year so i was home
four weeks
and yeah i go back to the hotel room
sometime you know i haven't eaten
because of the adrenaline
um and yeah it's very lonely and you're
like were youtube and what do i do
now yeah but 110 000 people screaming
your name
and you're performing i had the prince
or the king or the something to buy
dancing to strip that down oh wow i need
to get that one
country conveniently you can't strip it
down which i thought he was up dancing
yeah we were talking about the touring
here the touring park really messed up
so the hotel rooms
yeah a return of one yeah you know i i
saw like a thing of people being like
angry at x factor these last few weeks
and i wanted to say something about it
i don't really know what to say on my
terms because i feel like there's
obviously going to be some people in
there who are bitter
and you sign up for this show you don't
really know what the hell you're getting
yourself into but i would agree and i
we've actually gone out of our way as a
team to make this possible for me
and i think a record label just bought
into the idea
of what we've made and i was the guinea
pig
right so pick the craziest person in the
room to start with that's a good place
to start
and uh we made this this thing to like
care for people in the industry because
we don't have unions we don't have
people to look after us
and i was a kid you know i was a child
when this happened to me and i'm very
fortunate to still be here today to be
able to tell this story but for most
people
they feel abused or or something in some
sense
so i just think that there needs to
there needs to be a self-care
a care system within these shows because
if they're gonna
move people through these shows and use
them to make television
they can't just like let them off
afterwards and i could never watch
x-factor because i was always
heartbroken
because i'd been the guy who made it
really far and then got let go and it
ruined me when i was 14 i
was crap at school depressed like
it ruined me at one point but i've also
then been the guy who
i think my dad actually came out and
said it in in the thing we were filming
once he was like
you've been told no more than any
winning x factor contestant
or like any successful exercise thanks
dad it's great to know
what an unusual experience wild
if you were to tour again would you do
it differently would you have
i don't actually even know how i would
tour again i i really want to and and
like
i want to put i i always said throughout
this solo career i'd let my song book
speak to me
and i don't think my songbook has
necessarily spoke to me enough to get me
off my ass to go somewhere yet
i only became a solo artist because i
had to strip that down
i wasn't gonna do it i was gonna leave
it alone music yeah
i was gonna leave it hell alone i was
like survive once
thank you very much but now i'm back in
why
because the song i knew it was right it
felt right with the song whereas i
haven't had that and this this year
the song that we have i feel really
right about so i would rather let the
music do the talking than me
come out and try to force him i mean
he's such a fast-moving industry these
days it's one of the biggest races in
the world right if we had a start line
for how many musicians there are
trying to make it right now and who's
going to outwork the other one we'd need
a very big track
um so it's just kind of got to that
place that we don't need any more
useless music in the world
in my eyes it needs to mean something
said
there's something you know in the
previous answer that you've said online
which is
that you're lucky to be here one of the
most moving things i've ever
seen which honestly disturbed me and
stayed with me my entire life was that
avicii documentary
and the way that his management were
pushing him and he had social anxiety
and
oh god it just haunts me you know what
with those things
i mean i've spoken to managers who have
lost people in different and and you
know i've definitely put strain on a lot
of people in my life in the back you see
it let's be like a basically different
person i don't like talking about it
um you know i i think it's hard
it's just as hard for the team around
you at points as it is for you
because we didn't all know how the hell
we got here
everyone's kind of looking around like
we don't really know how the hell we got
here
so where's the next move and there's
always someone who will pull you through
i've been very
very fortunate now with the people that
i had to pull me through my my bits
um and it's you know and that's why i
say this care system is so
important right we music is the
lifeblood of a lot of our things it's
the background to our movie scenes when
we're sat in the back of the car looking
long fully out the window
but then we don't want to look after the
thing that's kind of feeding us that
much
you know what i mean so i think for
artists in the sense they do need that
i feel that it doesn't need to get lost
in translation in other things
it genuinely needs to be a care system
but then everyone's over therapy these
days in that sense anyway but it's like
if you want it it should be available
you know is that was that is there a
moment where you look back and say that
was
the lowest moment for me that was the
pivotal moment a few of them i was
worried how far my rock bottom was going
to be
where's rock bottom for me and you would
never have seen it i'm very good at
hiding it no one would have ever seen it
but rock bottom
i mean i don't even know if i hit it yet
you know what i mean i feel like it's
like one of those little graphs you see
when it's like oh we hit the
the uh you know my biggest support the
market support yeah it'll be there at
least
a support level oh my god you know it's
the same thing
so it feels like i can even make that
choice now and and pick my last moment
as my rock
at the bottom or i can make a new one
and make a whole new low that's my
choice you you said online that you were
you had previously been masking your
emotions and feelings
and this was something that you were
trying to trying to get over
um said you you tried to learn to deal
with your emotions instead of masking
them
how important has that been this is
something i really struggle with because
anyway because
i was ceo of a company you know 27 years
26 27 years old 700 employees
and that's wild wild is it all around
the world these adults are double my age
and i have to be right my business
partner
he'll tell you yeah he fell away right
alcoholic
upon all this weight depressive anxiety
fell away so
i'm carrying him because i need because
we're
we co-founders we're seen as a unit so
when he's out in the street and i don't
he won't mind me saying this because
he's been drinking all day with the team
and he's stealing bottles of wine off
other people's tables just total
strangers
and he's doing things in public which
you get arrested for
with parts of his body that i'm not
going to talk about when he's doing
those things
i'm getting a phone call i'm 26 and i
have to not only manage him
in my business partner but then i'm
having to manage all the impact that's
had on all of our employees
and i felt that i could never
talk or be vulnerable you are the thing
i find so
that's why i said it's not people don't
realize it's not
just you know and what happened to
avicii is terrible by the way and i
haven't seen the documentary i didn't
watch i actually knew someone who knew
who worked with him he wrote with me as
well and he said that what he saw was
going on was not good
but for the most part for a lot of these
people
there's usually somebody in there that's
not very good but
everyone else is trying to help and you
don't see the effect it's having on them
as well
you live and die by the sword i live and
die by myself that's it but the person
who's behind
trying to pick up the shield to help me
they haven't even got the [ __ ] sword
they're just
diving into battle for you and that's
the difference you know what i mean it's
like people miss out on that bit so it's
never
just on that person you know what i mean
a lot of my stuff first you know
if i hadn't had the help i had i don't
know where the hell i'd be right now so
that's a credit to you in a sense
it's um it's super super tough i think
with the um
the bit that i i really respect you for
though is you're
very open about it you talk about it you
talk about going to therapy you talk
about
your lows you talk about being unsure if
you would even be here
and that's going to do a lot good for a
lot of people i hope so i mean
like the worst bit for me is i think it
seems so much as a tool
these days to hide behind the points and
for me it's never about
that situation i'm just telling you as
what it is
and it's that's the bit where i think
like i say i don't want any of this to
get lost in translation i am not
one percent moaning about my life i i
love my life at the minute my life's
great
it's had it's upside it downs but it's
you know yeah i think i'd rather
talk about it and it's therapeutic for
me and it's been a really good chat by
the way this is a cool chat i like this
chat a lot
there's been some [ __ ] ones i mean
yeah because i'm genuinely asking you
questions that i give a [ __ ] about
yeah that's it that's the point though
and i'm telling you to think this if it
matters to me not trying to hide behind
some sort of
[ __ ] thing you know and like i say i
think there's
many people who have this effect on on
on therapy and all those things and
sobriety
and i ain't saying everyone at home by
the way should go sober
i ain't telling them to go vegan i ain't
telling him to do whatever i'm saying
this is what i did and it worked pretty
okay for me so far so you know
you're making you made a movie you wrote
a movie right i've been working on
something for a while and me and
christian spoke about a few weeks ago
and it's funny that it's based around
aaa but i had a really weird
aaa experience the first time that i
went into
well for anybody that doesn't know uh
alcoholics anonymous right um
and i my first experience was with
russell brand
which if you've seen game to the greek
or any of those other movies
i went to his house and i love
russell there's something about that
sentence which i can't get over my first
experience was with russell brandon okay
i mean yeah exactly all right so i'm in
his house i'm in this dude's house
and i've only seen him on the movies and
as a comic and i you know my bookie
wookie i love that stuff and like so i
know a lot of things about him but i'm
not i'm a really shy person when i first
i'm like oh my god like so he makes me a
coffee and we sit talking about our
experiences
and i've never seen someone look at me
the way he looked to me like find you a
man
who looks at you like russell brad looks
at you when he's listening to your
stories because he like
looks into your soul i was like i was
born again
and then we went to this meeting it was
an all male meeting and there was
everything in the meeting from prison
guards
to ex-soldiers to ex-cons to post-men to
bin men to everything and then me and
russell brand so i'm like this is the
weirdest room i've ever been in my life
we're in like some old like community
like
church room or whatever and then he's
he's taking the chair in the room
so my first experience with aaa was like
the best experience ever
because it was like he was just doing
stand up it was unbelievable he was
doing stand-up and then they aimed
no it's like they they have one who
chairs them
the idea is that if they say like oh can
you talk about uh relationships now as
affected by alcohol then he'll tell the
story of
his alcoholism or or you know narcotics
thing and then
you're linking from his experience to
god oh my god i'm the same as you and
that's
how it works um i'm gonna give the whole
script away because otherwise i'll tell
you the whole film
but i i kind of came up with this film
and i actually i haven't spoken to
russell
which is the first thing i have to do
because it was from him that this
obviously i'm in a movie right now like
and i'm one of the characters and i'm
sat here going i don't know what the
hell i'm doing here but apparently i'm
alcoholic and i've got a problem oh my
god
what's going on um the walls are closing
in
yeah exactly the wolf wall street was in
the corner over there i don't know
it was wild so it's i'm excited about it
and i think it's really funny i showed
it one of my friends
um and she was she really liked it she
left a lot of it so
we'll see quick one as a serial
entrepreneur that's currently building
multiple projects across multiple
industries everything from the marketing
industry to blockchain
to consumer goods everything one of the
things that has been a lifesaver for me
and again a company that i reached out
to to evangelize about on this podcast
because i'm a loyal customer
and they ultimately ended up sponsoring
this podcast is fiverr.com
f-i-v-e-r-r what that site allows me to
do
is extend my capacity across all of my
projects if i'm looking for a graphic
designer someone to
edit a video someone to do a website for
me
it allows me to extend my capacity
without hiring people and the quality of
freelancers on fiverr
has been amazing and when the the trust
and the service you get is that
phenomenal and
the services offered are that diverse
it's a no-brainer whether you have one
member of staff
you're a freelancer yourself or a
thousand members of staff five it can be
a game changer for you and i'd love you
guys to check it out
use the link below go to fiverr.com
ceo and send me a screenshot if you end
up using the service
one of you is going to win something
very amazing what else is um
what else is going on in your life in
terms of like business and investing
and projects and stuff like that when
you think about the direction of travel
that you want to take over the next 10
years
which direction do you want to focus on
and go in you're investing tons you've
got your own businesses now
everyone's going to say the same thing
to you every time you have an interview
they're going to say when is the reunion
i mean i've had wild my business
learning curve from the day i first got
my like first
check and i went to the manager i'm like
what do you invest your money in because
he had the biggest garden in london i
was like he's a good place to start he
had the biggest
home garden which you don't think he
does anymore steve do you
okay apparently he doesn't do more but
apparently he did when i was younger he
did
so i'm like trying to ask him like what
are you investing he's like on about
gold and whatever else then you learn
about safe haven currencies and all
these other things then i started to
branch out a little bit more a little
bit more
um then i went on to properties which
was always the one i wanted to do
and then when i was 19 i nearly bought
a fighting agency which was fun a
fighting agency
bammer i got bought into by bama when i
was 19.
so i roll up to this in like my like
burberry coat thinking i'm an absolute
bad man because i'm about to buy like
england's ufc oh okay okay fine right so
i go to this arena in manchester i'm
looking capacity he's not great
everything else but
i'm looking at all the stuff and you're
a kid so i'm a kid
and i mean i remember being in front row
of the fight and some guy behind me
obviously doesn't like the band very
much like sit down shut up whatever else
every fighter then after got out the
ring and shook my hand
and i just kept looking behind thinking
are you still got to say
do you know the guy with a scary clown
mask you just need that other guy's nose
off like he's my friend
he's myself i was like yeah exactly and
then and then i went met everybody
afterwards and i got into his company
but
unfortunately the deal wasn't great i
put it through one of my investors that
i have and then it's like people try to
catch you out
and this was always my biggest problem i
very fortunate to live in some lovely
places and every time someone would show
up at my door to
do something and the job would cost 500
pounds they would try and charge me 50
grand because the house was big
and i'm like learning early on like and
but don't get me wrong i've spent some
money on some stuff i shouldn't have
spent money on you and me both um
uh yeah i mean i'm going to go into
detail today
lots of money like my thing i always say
to people is like i will tell you
where i lost as much as i tell you where
i win you can't make mistakes though
right yeah hundred percent and
like my point is i'm not i'm gonna do
better than whatever my last mistake
wasn't
sure that's the point if i trust myself
enough it won't matter in the long run
when you think about money though you
know you didn't come from money you
didn't come back
when you started i read that your dad
had tons of debts and stuff like that
and
so you your relationship with money will
be very very different
as you've gone over the last decade um
than a lot of other people because to
you it's probably something that you
thought was you built up more when
you're younger right yeah and i think as
a kid
growing and especially if you like rap
music as well it becomes a computer
rap music made me spend a hell of a lot
of money um
i would say yeah i mean i have one of my
friends over recently and
my family my dad made decisions in our
house of what was going on and stuff and
he did them for the right reasons so i
stand by that and he doesn't need to
feel any pain in that whatsoever because
he wanted us to go on holiday
and go to america and he would bury
himself and he was so stressed he said
at one point in his life
he woke up and he couldn't remember his
own name because he was so far in debt
that he was only covering the interest
which i can't imagine how that feels
i mean it probably feels exactly same
how i feel some days with the other side
of it which is wild and we won't get
into that
but at one point in my life i mean my
friend um professional poker player now
but he was quite a rich kid at school
because he was like playing poker
since he was like 13. so when we would
go down to
to get breakfast i couldn't afford it
and he'd buy me like 20 p's worth of
toast
and i couldn't afford it
nice which is wild so then when you get
money i didn't know my family were poor
but they were [ __ ]
you know we were not in the good place
so how did that impact your relationship
with money when you finally got it
um were you a splurger would you
points yes on certain stuff i would but
not i'm more of a warrior than i was a
splurger
i was like because of where i lived and
where i was from i knew it could
disappear
so i was always really cautious about
protecting what i have and only spending
what i earn
that's money and happiness talk to me
about the link
a lot of people there isn't one yeah so
it's a myth
so i think money i think the way to
think about money and i mean there's a
beautiful thing i had as a kid
and when we used to go to church the
woman got a five pound note out
and she said uh have you ever read a
five pound note and i was like no i
haven't i was like five like now
and she's like uh if you read it it says
i promise to pay the bearer of this note
five pounds some money as promises which
i thought was great but if you develop
on that
and conversations i've had with people
money is is care
and the ability to relax on certain
things life's going to kick you in that
nut sometimes and you're going to need
something to help those around you
so it's never so much been for me about
spending money on me
and sometimes i have to remind myself to
shop because i'm terrible and i'm
one of those people who like will go on
a shop fill a basket and then just not
do the rest of it
i leave it there and i'm like oh yeah i
feel like i bought something now that's
good at least i did something fun with
what i'm
working my ass off for but i'm not like
that so it's like in terms of with
things with my family and different
things that happen like my dad's debt
for all those sorts of different reasons
i'd rather have it on hand and if
something
god forbid happens to any of us you know
my family are the last people that ever
asked me for anything i'm the first one
to go
this is why we do what we do you know
you have a son beautiful child
um he tells you that he's gonna
apply for axe factor someday this is a
tricky one
this is a trick i think his mom's hoping
he's going to become some like yoga
person
his mom's very chill these days um he
says i'm getting instagram and i'm going
to
do x factor what'd you say to him i mean
he's got the best
advice from the parents around him for
the long run i guess but
i don't know i i think is that one
obviously we protected his identity to
start off with
and that's not being pretentious or
anything other than the fact that
i want to give him a chance to be bare
first before he has to be oh
your mum and dad are so-and-so you know
and i made my choice to be where i was
at 14 15. so i figure he can make his
own choice then too we'll have a good
discussion about it a long discussion
because i know what effects that can
have as well um
but i would never stop him doing
something he wanted to do i'd let him
know the risks and i'd tell him what was
going to happen
you know and and and better that than
you know
my parents didn't really ever experience
any of the things i've experienced
before i got this they had no idea what
i was signing
up for would they change it probably not
but they would change some things that
happened in between
across the way i bet 100
so he says he's going to do the show you
give him the disclaimer and the warning
um what would you rather he did if you
could as a dad you could be that
authoritarian
you could choose would it be to walk in
your face something that he enjoys do
enjoys doing every day and i mean that's
i say that lightly because i think
everything that you do depending on what
kind of person you are becomes
annoying at a point doesn't matter what
job you do it's not how i really got to
do that again you know like my dad i
used to think my dad's job was the best
job ever like build an airplane
adult lego like i said as my dad's like
do not end up in that bloody factory
that's the last thing you're going to do
um would you want him to follow in your
footsteps though
uh i hope we did it better than i did
really yeah
i don't know i think um sometimes you
can get lost in the connection part of
this game and i think that's always been
a difficult thing for me to connect with
people because i put so many barriers up
before you get to actually what's going
on that you
you know it's almost like hurdling them
in a way why do you think those barriers
are up
protection i think it's protecting
people from what's you know if you turn
up in the disguise every time then you
can always blame it on the disguise the
moment you're not wearing one you've got
nothing to blame it on
and what what is it that your your
manager over there stephen would know
about you
that you probably i know in terms of
like
in a box in terms of like what you know
someone who knows you very well
would um say about you that we wouldn't
expect
just from what we see online you talk
because you talk a lot about this
wearing this mask and you know being
wearing a disguise even in your
relationships i'm really trying to
understand because
we've been we've been here maybe now for
two hours whatever and as time goes on
and on and on you get to know someone a
bit better
you know and like my barrier goes down a
bit yours goes down a bit we get more
comfortable
and i'm like who is that person behind
there that people don't know because
i don't know i mean i think in certain
part for me having to translate it for
music
is difficult and i am opinionated to an
extent sometimes they can get me in
trouble with some [ __ ] and i hate that
that really does annoy me because it's
like
everyone's into hard to so they want to
say about something right you can
disagree on you know
yeah but i think for me i hide behind
humor a lot
i make everything i can funny and then
that will leave it to not be as
offensive okay interesting
i really want to i really want to get an
idea of when you you look towards the
future professionally
what are the what what is the
positioning that liam payne is
is hoping for you i guess you know from
what you've described for bear
you just want to be doing things you
enjoy yeah i think so and i think that's
you know there's
been a slow road up to that point and
it's just doing things for the right
reasons i mean
we're in a beautiful age right now you
are your own press
which is actually great for artists if
we learn to do it the right way
this whole thing i used to hate was
going on and off
talk shows going on and off and doing
this doing everything else that seemed
to be for everybody else and it was
promo in your record
but then the record bites and you get
nothing out of it and it's like
everybody else got there five minutes
but the record just didn't do what it
wanted so it's like
you know i want to experiment with the
way i promo my records so make sure that
the record is taken before i go and
halfway around the world it's going oh
look this is this great song and then no
one hears it oh
great well you know what i mean but it's
like almost you know i think the music
industry and
listen up people i think the music
industry is in a place where people
need to throw out the old the old
you know marketing format for these
things and it's almost like when you see
companies that try and do tick tocks
don't do it like that because we can see
right through what you're doing
you've made a tick tock and haha we're
supposed to laugh but it's not funny
and it's the same for the music industry
it's like there's a new way that people
are promoting things now
you know billy eilish came from a
bedroom and did this and did it
and it worked out really well but it
wasn't the same format that you used
back in 2010 even i mean
the way the industry's changed while
i've been in it it's been wild and i've
only been here
i've been here a decade just over a
decade now but it's insane but i just
think
record labels and and sometimes people
spend budget on stuff that they don't
need to do
you have your format you have your fan
base grow it organically properly
not not through you know
i don't know the way we're doing things
at the moment because sometimes it's
just i don't know why the hell we're
doing this
social media your relationship with it
that's been my industry for the last
decade um good thing bad thing
what's your relationship with at the
moment i think it's good
i think it's a difficult thing to manage
i love the idea of what tik tok does
but for me i don't get sucked into my
phone
with like watching stuff constantly and
you do and you need to be on your
on your like learning stuff and and you
know it's start funny video whatever
else
but if you're for you page it's just
like funny dogs and
yeah it's [ __ ] then you're in a what
the hell's going on you know that's what
that's what it does to me i'm like
god really so i i don't know it's um
i've seen a lot of different technology
coming in and go out of my industry from
the time
from twitter and you know i honestly
think there's a strong
case for saying that we owe a little bit
of our success to the way twitter was
because worldwide trends weren't a thing
before one direction
before one direction one x factor
whereas on that night we could trend
everywhere
and then people would go oh my god
what's this so you know magically oh the
biggest band on xbox was the same time
twitter came out it doesn't it's perfect
storm stuff you know
um so i think it's great i think we have
a funny way
like i say with the coins that you know
the
markets just had the most weird few
months of people making hoe coin hog ho
coin plus
ho coin extra ho koi in this and there's
90 of them and i'm hearing all of my
friends going oh did you buy
doggy doo doos 21 no no no i bought star
star porn over there you know i mean i'm
like what the hell have we do we doing
we're talking in code
you know and it's like that but rather
than the technology that works ripple
ethereum you know things that have
real world application rather than coins
that are
hey everyone i made a coin that's about
you know tripods for cameras
this tends to happen at this i think at
the start of these like exponential
bubbles you get this and then it weeds
out the crap weeds aren't the crowd
that's
what's happened recently to me like the
markets took a big dip because they're
trying to weed out some of the
the stupid stuff and because it's an
unregulated thing it's like
but i find that that's with the same
with social media we need to weed out
the bad stuff and focus on the good
there's a lot of debate at the moment
because of the racism that some
footballers footballers have experienced
marcus rashford did a big post the other
day
that uh you know how do we how do we
stop people putting monkey emojis or any
kinds of like abuse
on you know because what happened what i
think is happening from a
psychological standpoint is they see
liam payne they think he is
up there on that mountain that is not a
human being if i throw a rock
and i hit i might get a little bit of
attention from him
so they they pick up a rock that's why
i'm saying to you to start about
bringing people up to your level in a
way
but it's not so much for them that they
could they can get away from from
from not saying something about that you
know and i mean they have to speak up
about it and it's difficult and
we are going through a really fast
moving area with everything in the
moment i mean you wish there was an
algorithm that would just beat that
right but they will find some way of
spelling it differently and it will just
you know verify i think they verify
everybody's idea i think that would kill
99 percent of it yeah
i actually thought of a thing for this
for voting
because voting for me was always a
really difficult thing we all have our
iphones we have our thumbprint that goes
on why can't we verify fire thumbprint
to get accounts and then that's on your
record
there's that great black mirror episode
where that woman's going through life
trying to get these likes and she's like
desperate
oh i got a please i need to be in this
neighborhood but i know i was a five
star this morning like oh my god
you need a horrible crap on the way
darling i'm sorry but that's what
life will eventually be policed by i
imagine in a way
speaking of black mirror um i guess this
is a strange tangent but um i
i when i had johan hari on the podcast
last week one of the key themes here is
that
all this technology and social media has
like taken the meaning out of our lives
because like dating now happens on these
screens
people order their food by like tap tap
tap and it shows up at the door um
even now with covid um we're now working
from screens we used to have an office
or you know offices we could go to now
it's all screens
and it feels like the world is getting
more and more so what's amazing is we we
were all so worried about technology
pushing us away from each other when
kobe hit right
yeah it was the only thing that saved us
thank god
when kobe did hit which i thought said a
lot more about technology's good sides
than they did about the bad sides i mean
it's up to you how you use your platform
in the end and what you let it do to you
like i say i enjoy tik tok but i watch a
few videos and i watch things that
people send me i don't
really have a for you page i don't
really go through it constantly
because there's you know
i mean it's difficult with kids and
screens man i i have one and i watch him
and i'm like i really want to like
you know we go i make him go out and do
stuff and sometimes we fall out
big we have rows about really yeah yeah
it's not sometimes it's not good
um but he's learning with it you know
and it's that it's
like you say for all of us we are the
guinea pig generation for these things
we're learning you know we're the first
yeah we're the kind of civilization to
be affected by an algorithm and to be
connected
what about the people who first
experienced hay fever they figured out
their way around that you know what i
mean it's like
for me it seems like we will figure out
the right things of it but it's weeding
out the bad sides of it and what it does
like i think if your tick tock screen is
advice
and videos about learning stuff or like
stuff that you're actually really
interested in you enjoy
not just random funny crap because
that's what
you've been framed was right you want to
find yourself watching you've been
framed all day
really because that's what you're doing
or even worse on instagram
keeping up with the kardashians oh look
she's amazing she's 10 out of 10. oh and
she's rich well her life's perfect and
look at my live site here in my box you
should see this pot noodle
with my cellulite yeah but that's
actually the illusion because i i bet
you
of course it's an illusion but it's an
asian design to destroy your self-esteem
isn't it
it's like yeah but i also think there's
i think there's a fine line between
these
these these things and and accepting and
accepting everybody and all this stuff
is is a given
but i don't think that in the process of
that we want to lose
the thing to settle for ourselves you
know there was a big debate about me on
on loose swimming at one point uh i was
all right with it was okay i
understood what they were saying but i
worked really hard for for what i did in
my underwear commercial you know
and it was my it did overtake my life in
certain respects yeah for sure it did
but it was actually an aim of mine it's
one of the only things i've ever aimed
for was to try and do an underwear
commercial so
i remember i went to my meeting with the
company i was working with and they were
like no no we don't want to do that with
you and i was like no trust me
just trust me and they gave they
preferred them they put their trust in
me i went and trained my ass off and i
got myself
where i wanted to be but then it was
like people worrying about people's
self-esteem looking at the picture and
whatever else i get that
but i quite enjoyed the idea of looking
at someone and being like wow he's
that's cool man like i'm gonna go and
get that
why did you want an underwear commercial
i just thought i could do it i thought i
could
and i wanted to challenge myself in the
gym to it was you know it's hard to be
strictly about look in the gym
sure not function which that was the bit
i battled with myself a little bit but
it's like
yeah i i think you know you want to go
out and get it going and get it it's it
but i don't think we should
like i say in accepting everybody let's
not lose
the idea of striving for something as
well though because it's alright to say
yeah i'm
i'm perfect was that an advert i saw
somewhere the other day and i thought
are we really that narcissistic do we
have to call
ourselves perfect for everyone to be
okay with each other like
and like i might get in trouble for
saying some of this stuff but it's just
like my thought is like
i want to teach the next generation to
strive for things as much as i wanted
for them to feel confident in themselves
but it's like it's almost like being a
parent right you're gonna mess them up
somehow like if we start saying we're
perfect i guarantee next we'll be like
well that's not worked out well so let's
rewrite the plan on that one
you know and it's i just think
everyone's you know give each other a
break and just
go do what you like have you have you
figure
it's taken me some time um to try and
understand
what it is that actually makes me happy
yeah i used to once upon a time when i
was broke this is a big one yeah
i used to i was gonna end on this big
question but i used to think it was like
oh i'll get a lamborghini and then i'll
be happy
and like that's why my book is called
happy sexy millionaire because i i
thought that i wrote in the first page
of my daughter at 18.
i wrote range rovers bear in mind i
didn't have a drama listen and i was
stealing chicago time pizzas at the time
um range rover sport will be my first
car i'll make a million before i'm 25.
i'll get a really hot girlfriend
and i'll work on my body image what i
meant is i'll get a six-pack i just
don't want to write that
and i thought that is the goal of life i
get those things range rover was my
first car i made a mini profit five
and i'm like where is the confetti and
if that's not it then what the [ __ ] is
life
i mean what happens when you wake up and
every day is a dream
i mean i don't mess you up i often have
looked for the moment in life where i
bang my head and i might be in some sort
of commerce
dream that i've invented for myself like
that i was that messed up as somebody i
was like i'm sure this is the simulation
guys
like i must have made this wall because
i can't be here because of where i was
yesterday
yeah so it was you know there's those
wild things that if you let them creep
in they will
f you up bad someone says something to
be quite interesting the other day
our view of what we hunt for as humans
has changed we don't hunt for food
anymore we hunt for success
it's almost like the target went from
animals and corn and food
to friggin lamborghinis and
and that sort of stuff but that's what
we strive for now at like even point
like you were saying earlier about
you're you're so glad you're here
because that supplements your food
sometimes you're that driven by
your drive that you forget you're gonna
eat sometimes and i was the same at work
oh my god i'm terrible
like i'm known for skipping lunch breaks
and working through the day to get home
quicker
because i can go without i'll just
muster on through but think about that
you've gone past your basic survival
instinct to you're writing against your
health for
like yeah coins yeah exactly but i might
miss this thing
good that i'm exactly the same it's
something i think that we struggle with
in in this respect and it's like
priorities i don't know anything about
what makes me happy at this point i
really don't
really no i really i've i've found a
couple of things that i think i'm
interested in
but like the thing is once you start
making money on these scales and things
that happen
it only becomes the drive that's
interesting to you if it's gonna
fast-forward you somehow and that's not
that toxic thing that we've funny enough
we've come full circle but that's
it's the same sort of thing and i think
i think it's a big problem for me
because if it's not i'm thinking why am
i and that's why drawing for me was the
biggest one of the time
because i was like this is what children
do why should i do this and then funny
that i drew something that was about
being a child was that
it's weird how things go full circle in
that respect
but yeah it's i often struggle to get on
with something if i don't think it's
forwarding me in life somehow
rather than just enjoying the moment or
going out and watching the sunset one of
my one of my biggest things
made me happy while i was training was
4am getting up in the dark and this
sounds like
i am some sort of psychopath and i was
but
you're like go into the park run for a
little bit and then stand another thing
and watch the sunrise
was the best thing and you know why it's
[ __ ] free
you can stand and watch your sunrise and
go wow thanks for another day sort of
thing i know that sounds really woosar
and like really far out spiritual but i
didn't for me it wasn't like that i just
enjoyed seeing how beautiful this moment
was and i was the only person in hyde
park running
at 4am every single day and it was some
of the best time i've had in life
they've done studies kind of linking to
what you're saying there where
if they give someone a game and i wrote
about this a little bit if they give
someone a game that they enjoy
people will do it and they'll have high
motivation to do it
if you then pay the same person to do
the same game
their motivation will decrease i have a
big problem with this so you can love
doing something
and then the minute you the reward
starts to become extrinsic which is
external which is money
your motivation decreases and this is
why it's it's very very important even
for me with this podcast i started it
because i love doing it love meeting
people
when it starts becoming a commercial
thing it moves into being a job and then
the science says
my motivation will decrease so it's
interesting though because you talked
about your drawing you started drawing
because it was a
and then it becomes this and it becomes
an nfc and then it becomes a business
and then you know
what to do and then you're like oh my
god i don't want to do this i'm here
again yeah exactly yeah exactly
you said you've not figured out what
makes you happy definitely not yet now
that's me in a few years and i i think
i mean so what have what's my conclusive
point been for what makes me happy
professionally it's super clear for me
now having a and these are keywords so
a worthwhile um challenge
that i'm doing with people that i love
and i've i i've come i've
come up with that based on a ton of
things some of the things you've said
fit perfectly into it
when you look at tyson fury when he's
not in the gym depressed when you look
at goal um olympians
whether they win or lose at the olympics
they get depression because they've
reached the mountaintop and there's
nothing else to strive for
and so when i was going through my notes
i was thinking the day that someone
offered me 50 odd million to buy my
business
was one of the worst days of my life and
gary vaynerchuk i know you're doing some
stuff with him
he says the same thing when i spoke to
him on the podcast he was like the day
when i buy the new york jets
will be the worst day of my life he's
like i hope it happens
on my deathbed because not having
something to strive for
and this has been a big struggle of mine
for men you lose orientation
yeah right when you're training for the
olympics we're going this way this is
our purpose in life
when the olympics is over you ain't got
no [ __ ] direction you're like well i
mean look at this
and talking about direction my that
whole thing for me and that mountain for
me was 1d
and music after that like i said you're
never going to keep up with what we did
like we sold so many records and we did
some we broke so many records we did so
many things
you know i mean we were in stadiums
every day 94 000 people every day like i
was in like i used to break into wembley
stadium
on the night time because it was fun and
i was smashed and i thought these people
aren't going to recognize me
i've broken into every major stadium in
america honestly and people used to
chase us on these like
police like little squad bikes being
like hey sir you're not supposed to be
in here and we'd run because it's like a
game attack
i swear to god it was this one time we
we opened up a door and found a zamboni
you know the thing that squashes the
eyes and we accidentally emptied the
like two tonne of water on the floor i
don't know i might have to pay for that
night
um yeah so once you reach that height
i suppose one of the reasons i struggled
the most out of it is because you're
never really going to reach that height
again and then it's almost
like a limbo and also not knowing
whether or not we're going to come back
are we going to come back everyone's
asking i don't know and it feels like
pressure to come back
it's almost like your your parents going
when's baby two are coming you know what
i mean
now we gotta have another one so that's
that's wild to me and
and and having to deal with that at a
young age i was i was always going to
mess it up somewhere
is what i would say about myself because
that's like he says the worst day ever
you know the day the band ended i was
like thank lord for that and i know a
lot of people are gonna be mad at me for
saying that but i needed to stop
or it would kill me um and i was like
thank the lord and then after that
trying to like
funnel your way back into society be
like hey guys i'm still here
turning up at tesco's in a lamborghini
like an idiot
you know i'm like what the [ __ ] am i
doing and
and for a lot of that yeah i agree with
a lot of that
that statement it's you need to have
something to strive for and i feel like
i'm finding that a little bit more now
and learning to relax yeah you've talked
a lot about this
learning to relax learning to just be
you know a lot of people
be part of the moment man be in the
moment and like i'm like this is
[ __ ] but
it's true if you can just sit you know
and enjoy something for what it is for
five minutes
have you tried meditation my ex
uh cheryl is very big on meditation
um she sent me one the other day and i
got told off for not doing it again
meditation gets me in trouble these days
um no i need to i i
did a couple of things in meditation
with my old personal trainer that were
quite good
but i just my mind's so [ __ ] busy
i can't shut it up like the moment i'm
trying to not think about so i'm like oh
yeah but what about if we just did this
next week and
i know you'll be exactly the same that's
what i'm saying i'm like trying so
[ __ ] hard with this meditation
let's do it together every morning and
i'm like steve close the tabs
and every morning i'm sat there and i
love that on the [ __ ] floor of my
shower because it's like it's like it
looks like it's
from thailand and the water's pouring
and i'm like just don't think about
anything and then i'm like
i'm planning all my schedule in my head
i'm like liam's coming for the podcast
man
what should i speak to him about and
then you know john will be doing the two
senses thing where you like
think of like what you can hear what you
can smell i've tried all of them i've
tried this one with beads where you like
hold the beads and you just
like the simulation
not bad he's good in the shower as well
if you like close your eyes then pick
two senses
which you can choose like feel oh
interesting so your mind can only
do two senses at once so once you shut
some of them off that's technically
meditation because you're in the moment
but i still don't feel like i've had
that you know i'm not a monk at this
point i wish i was i think it's
important though
i do i get it i do understand it but i
also think
imagine if you could get your mind just
to be in the present moment fully
and just be if i could have done that at
school i hadn't been
i've been top of the class but my mind's
going oh yeah what are we going to do
lunch time i'm not going to give up so
i'm going to keep trying every morning
naked on
my bathroom floor that's what i want to
keep doing
worthwhile challenge with people you
love
so worthwhile you define it yourself
right challenge means it can't be easy
because then your
motivation won't be high and then
surrounded by people you love
for me that is where i've figured out my
happiness lives
and so upon leaving my company that i'd
founded for ten years now i'm like
learning to dj doing a big theatrical
play at the albert hall which we've
directed and produced i'm just trying
i'm throwing my hand at everything
biotech
no i'm the same you know and that's what
i was thinking with you
from what you were saying like you're
never gonna top that mountain so where's
what is the mountain i mean we've done
so many
random you know the trip to namibia
without was one of the things and we
jumped we did a
world first of the canyon swing in
namibia which was
really crazy and wild and i thought i
might die on national television but
that is okay
um what else did we do are doing this
nft things really interesting
um doing the online shows because we
were one of the first people to really
like pioneer with the company
you know my team were massive massive
behind that um but it was almost like
making a tv show every week with new
songs and songs i hadn't sang since
whatever songs i'd never heard before
and i just would turn up and do it we
did really really well and i loved that
um i don't know i've had i think i've
had many many many jobs i've got like a
laundry list
to the point where when the sensors came
i didn't know what the hell to write i
didn't want to write performer because i
think it just sounds like such a badge
off job of like
it doesn't it doesn't encapsulate
anything that i actually
do i mean we design clothes for hugo
underwear modeling
loads of stuff so um do you think maybe
you just need a really big
[ __ ] scary terrifying goal that you
really care about well i mean
someone had asked me to go and do
everest at one point and i was like
i don't know i might die on that one but
does that not make you a little bit like
right now we've got something to aim for
get in the gym yeah i mean
in a way i'm already there's something
i'm cooking up in my brain i'm not gonna
i'm not going to talk about here okay
doesn't come off but i'm cooking
something up at the moment it's very dim
orientated i'm definitely going to give
it a big
big go some things piss me off um
interesting um
and i thought i just had to do it um the
one thing i say what the one thing i'll
say about success and
about these things if i'm honest about
happiness i think it's learning to have
respect for yourself
i mean there's a lot of things people
say about don't base yourself on others
and never look at other people in that
way which i actually think you need to
throw out the window
because there's when i was like it's
almost weird i learned it from my
character design when i was designing
coats i didn't start from nowhere and
how i learned to design characters was
like
how do you make a dragon have you never
seen one i don't know why dragon anyone
so they mix it with a with uh exactly
this is funny so they mix it with a lion
mixed with a snake mixed with a
crocodile mixed with a dinosaur
because they're the ones that we have so
they base them off of stuff so i like
look at people who are my heroes and i
think what is it that i love about them
that i don't think i
possess yet and then that's how you know
you can respect yourself and i think
that's the most important thing for me
is if i get up in the morning i respect
myself i go to bed
on night time i respect myself i'm happy
but
certain things are about my life and
even this moment i want to change but
it's like christian bale for example i
love his acting
girl like go-to and i mean some things
he's done his career have been really
unhealthy when he did the machinists and
stuff like that but
i like that drive and i like the fact
that he like buries himself into a role
and stuff and i've never learned that
quite yet so that might be one of the
things i want to
steal exactly if it's almost yeah it's
like taking people's stuff but
you're molding it into your own
character we were talking today about
avatars which is obviously a huge
market at the moment people spend so
much time on their avatars
on their games when they've started
something but in life you are your
avatar
you do whatever you want and it's like
if you're making your avatar and you've
got to go and do 10 free kicks to earn
the next ronaldo but you're like oh i'll
get in there and do them
the moment someone asks you to do
something in life to earn something
you're like oh i don't want to do it
but it's like that's why i was trying to
think how we explain that to kids but
that's the most basic
analogy i can come up with you know
children's book children's book i had an
idea for children's book actually but we
didn't finish it
that's a lot of the real things about
look at why he's smiling at me
well we've talked about so much today um
so much so much inspiration and
you know a lot of the questions i asked
are based on so
it's amazing amazing conversation and um
i really really respect and appreciate
your willingness to be open and honest
about all these things because you're
helping so many people you don't even
realize it
i i do hope so you know and um i think
you're just a
tremendously inspirational guy you're
you know an incredible entrepreneur
which i don't think people are fully
um appreciated yet because you're very
you're not you've not sort of disclosed
all of the investments and businesses
you're involved in but i think that's
certainly coming i think we might have a
bit of a
a european action culture on our hands
if i say so myself
um but yeah thank you mate honestly you
know you've been through what is
a unique just tremendously unique
experience over the last decade nobody
can understand it other than probably
the boys you did it with
and uh from that you know there's ups
there's downs but this is life right and
um you sharing it has brought tremendous
value for me so i know it will
definitely bring
huge value for our audience so i just
want to say thank you no i think mate
thank honest this has been one of the
best chats i've ever done
thank you i'm excited to see what you
bring to the table on dragon's den i
can't wait to watch it
i'm buzzing i'm buzzing maybe you can
come in with uh some of your ideas
though i know i'll come and pitch
something
can you imagine you should be a dragon
ball style i was actually maybe not
coming in disguise
we'll do one week where i'll like deck
the [ __ ] out of here i'll just come on
and be like right i've got this idea for
swimming pools on roofs would you ever
be a dragon
um oh i think i'd be a terrible dragon
i don't know i feel bad for people and i
wanna like oh no just like i'll buy it
i'll take it thank you brother
appreciate you i appreciate thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you